well thank you for coming and thank you
for the introduction as you said my name
is Lily and I am a product manager for
Open Knowledge Foundation and I work on
the frictionless data for reproducible
research project and my background is in
neuroscience and I feel like I'm in good
company because they've already been two
Talk's today by neuroscientist which is
kind of a funny coincidence but I am
working in open data and open source
research now and today I'll be telling
you about our project frictionless data
and how we are working with the
researcher community to help them
resolve their data pipeline issues using
this open source software and I want to
point out two things I have the link to
the slides posted here it's this bitly
link and I put that up there because
there's lots of links in the slides that
for later after the talk if you want to
get the slides and go in and explore
more content and there's lots of links
and I will probably tweet out the link
to these slides so you can find it that
way as well and we are hiring a Python
developer right now so there's info the
at that link at the top and if you want
to learn more you can come talk to me
later about that so I know we just ate
lunch and I thought that it would be
good to start this talk by talking about
data in a food question so here's my
question that I want to talk start with
if the slides will progress they're not
progressing
they were you okay here's my very
important question for you as the water
temperature in the Gulf rises will this
lead to less shrimp which could lead to
less shrimp tacos in Austin and we can
argue about what the best taco filling
is later but I put up this question to
start thinking about data and what kind
of data can we use to answer this
question we can you know ask about the
lifespan of shrimp in the Gulf we can
collect data points about the
temperature of the water in the Gulf and
say then we could you know map it out
plot it and do an analysis and then we
would know the answer to this question
right pretty straightforward but it's
actually not straightforward at all I'm
leaving out all of the parts that you do
with the data before you get to the
actual analysis steps you know things
like data management and collecting the
data and understanding the background of
the data to really be able to work with
the data you know things like what time
of day were you collecting those data
points about the temperature of the
water questions about you know where
those data points collected from the
same species of shrimp and these are the
questions that are really important that
we sometimes overlook when we're handed
data and then do analysis with it and so
I really want you to keep in mind these
kinds of questions in this aspect of
data management because that's what
we're gonna be talking about today
and I wanted to start with this kind of
silly question but this is actually a
really important thing to be mindful of
because in real life science has a
reproducibility problem and for those of
you that aren't super familiar with the
research science world I'll tell you a
little bit more about that it means
sometimes experiments cannot be easily
repeated or when they are repeated they
result in different data or different
results and why is this happening
there's a lot of debate right now about
what could be leading to the
reproducibility crisis but we know part
of it is that oftentimes the methods
describing an experiment are not being
published in full
that results are being published so it's
really difficult to know exactly what
happened with that data or sometimes the
results in data are not shared openly so
this means that only select people have
access to the results and data and not
everyone can understand what exactly
happened with that data for instance and
why is this happening it's not that
researchers you know aren't smart people
it's just that oftentimes they don't
know how to manage their data and they
don't know how to document their data
well and that's because no one teaches
you typically no one taught me how to
manage my data when I was in grad school
you know my analysis was written on a
sticky note that I put on my computer
and you know like I knew what it meant
but nobody else did and it's not
repeatable at all so this is a real
problem in 2017 there was an analysis
done where this Belmont Forum group
asked scientists what their top issues
were and working with data and these are
the top four scientist often don't know
how to work with complex data they
there's a lack of data standards in
their field it's difficult to find
relevant data and also data management
and storage or big issues and I say here
researchers lack these skills but many
people that work with data lack these
skills as well and so these are the main
inspiration for the frictionless data
for reproducible research project which
is the project that I work with and so
I'm gonna be telling you more about the
group I work for open knowledge
foundation and this frictionless data
project and getting into the technical
details behind that and then I'm going
to be showing you a case study with this
group called B Co demo which is
oceanographers oceanography data
managers and then ya so you can see how
we're working with their pipelines okay
so you begin the Open Knowledge
Foundation is a non-profit it was
incorporated 15 years ago and our main
goal is to open up all knowledge we
really fight for a fair free and open
future we're all per non personal
information is available and then we're
trying to open this
up and give it to people so they can use
it and also trying to build communities
tools and teach skills to people so that
they can use this knowledge to really
push positive social change we have a
fully remote team I'm the only person in
Austin everyone else's around the world
and we have a large global network we
have groups in over 40 countries and
then we work on many different projects
from working with governments to try to
open up their spending data to working
with local libraries to try and make
them be hubs for public data and then
also this frictionless data project that
I will tell you about more now so the
main idea and the frictionless data
project is to remove friction and
research data so we can get from raw
data to insite faster and these are
pictures of my team it's a very small
team and we're all open source and we're
community focused and by community
focused I mean that we really depend on
our community members to help with the
project by using our tools and asking
questions and giving feedback and asking
for improvements so while I have four of
us pictured here there's a lot of people
in our community that I want to thank as
well for really helping us and
constantly pushing forward work on this
project and here's the link to our
github repository and there will be
again a lot more links in here that you
can look at later they tell you a little
bit more about this project we are grant
funded we're funded by the Alfred Alfred
P sloan Foundation and then we're
overseen by the Open Knowledge
Foundation we work with researchers in a
variety of collaborations and the first
is fellows where we are working with
early career researchers to teach them
data management best practices and teach
them about open science principles and
how to use the frictionless tooling
we're working for the tool fund we're
working with developers to help build
new tools for reproducible research and
then the pilot projects are a really
intensive one-on-one collaboration with
specific researcher groups to try and
resolve their data workflow issues
and I'll be focusing on the pilot
project when I talk about our
oceanography collaboration so what is
frictionless data I've said that word a
lot in the past few minutes and the idea
behind frictionless data is removing
frictions from working with data but
what does that mean these are the steps
like the data cleaning steps the steps I
was talking about with the shrimp tacos
things like what's the license for this
data what does this specific data value
even mean can I use ecstatic was created
in Excel and use it in Python without
having any problems who created the data
and also checking for the quality of the
data these are all of the things that
you need to know to understand how to
use the data and that can be very
time-consuming so this project we are
working to remove these frictions and we
have backbone of the project our
specifications for data and metadata
interoperability and then also a
collection of open source software
libraries that work with these
specifications and we also have a range
of best practices and then importantly
all of this is platform agnostic because
we're really trying to support
interoperability at the core of
frictionless data is the data package
which is a simple container for data and
metadata and to help you wrap your head
around what that looks like I like to
use this idea of a shipping container
that contains data so inside of our data
package shipping container we have our
data and typically we work with tabular
data so have a csv file as an example
and then along with the data you have
its associated metadata and for those of
you that have never heard the term
metadata before it's the data about data
is the description of that and it's
things like what's the license who
created the data you know what format is
the data in and then optionally you can
also include a schema inside the data
package and this tells you information
about the format of your data so we can
tell you you know like how many rows and
columns you have or it could tell you
what you're missing values mean it can
tell you a very important information
about the contents of that data and
together all of this is the data package
and help you think more about why
packaging data is useful and I'm using
Legos I'm sure many of you have used
Legos before and one of the best things
about Legos is that you can take LEGO
pieces from different sets of Lego and
they work immediately with each other
you don't have to do anything to you
know build something out of multiple
sets and this is the same idea with the
data package and it's interoperability
is that you can think of different tools
as different LEGO pieces that you can
automatically work with the data package
because it's so interoperable and you
know for instance you can take the data
package and immediately work with it in
pandas or our and we also have our own
open-source tool called good tables that
I'll tell you about more as well in a
minute hey this is a screenshot of some
of the software that we have this is a
screenshot from our website and I just
want to show you this because we have a
lot of software and our main libraries
are in Python but we have most of the
libraries translated into other
languages as well like JavaScript and R
and Ruby for example and if you are
interested in any of these other
languages I encourage you to check out
our website and again the github
repository ok so since we're at PI data
I'm gonna focus on the Python libraries
and we have four main Python libraries
that we use for frictionless data the
first is called data package pi and this
is useful for creating and using data
packages and so what this means is like
if you have a csv file or a data file
then you can put it in data package pi
and you can automatically infer metadata
about that csv file and then you can
package it together and export it and
use it with different tools the table
schema library is
useful for writing data schemas and
again this describes the data so again
you could have a CSV file and then table
schema will automatically infer the
schema based off of that CSV file and
then we have good tables which is for
validating your your data with or
without a schema and so the way this
works is say you have a CSV file and you
then want to be able to validate and
make sure that say like every data value
in column a should be a string then you
can do that with it good tables and with
your schema and then the final library
I'm gonna focus on more in a few slides
but this is data package pipelines and
this is kind of combining all of the
previous steps into processing pipelines
so the real reason why we have these
libraries is to help remove friction and
the data and so I have two use cases of
how they are helpful for removing the
friction and the first is you have a
user he opens up a CSV file and says
what does this data even mean I don't
know what this code in the data means
and the reason that that can be
difficult is because you don't have good
metadata associated with it or like a
data dictionary but if you have your
data packaged into a data package then
you have that metadata present and also
the metadata is machine readable I think
I forgot to say that that we always have
the metadata in JSON so it's machine
readable which helps with the
interoperability as well and then my
favorite use case the second one is when
somebody is using Excel and they say oh
no Excel converted a value in my data
without telling me and this actually
happens in science fairly frequently
there are these horror stories about
genes that are sound like dates so for
instance there's a gene de 7 which Excel
automatically converts to December 7th
and it doesn't tell you what's doing it
it just does it silently so if you have
thousands of pieces of data and you have
these genes present you might not notice
that Excel changed the content of your
file and so there have actually been
research studies that were published
that had to be revoked because the
analysis was incorrect because the
researchers had analyzed their gene they
thought they were analyzing gene names
and they weren't so a way to avoid this
is validating your data and it really
helps to have a schema to be able to do
this and so good tables allows us to
validate the database on a schema and it
will tell you you know column a is
supposed to be strings but I detected a
date format in this row and it will give
you an error and it will tell you
exactly what the error is and where the
error was found so that you can go in
and manually change that data value back
so this is very helpful ok now I want to
talk more about data package pipelines
because this is what I'll be talking
about when I get to the use case data
package pipelines is a Python framework
for declarative processing of tabular
data the pipelines are defined in a file
called pipeline spec and it's a Yambol
file so it's human readable and inside
this pipeline spec file we have
specified the processor steps that are
taken during the pipeline they also have
the execution parameters and so this
allows the pipeline to be reproducible
because we have a record that's human
readable of everything that happened
during that process and then DPP also
includes standard data processing steps
out of the box you know things like
joins find and replace and remove a
column or unfit but in addition to these
standard processor steps you can write
custom processor steps for your own use
case and this is in Python again and
then the output of the data package
pipelines is a single data package so
you have your data you have your
metadata in JSON and then you also have
this pipeline spec file and
oops again all of this makes it very
repeatable process and helps with
reproducibility and again here's a link
to the github repository where you can
see this code okay so now I'm gonna
switch and start talking about our use
case so this is a collaboration with
this group called be Co demo and that
stands for a biological and chemical
oceanography data management office it's
a mouthful and that they are a group
that is a repository for all
oceanography data that is produced by
researchers that are funded by the NSF
which is the National Science Foundation
which is a really big science funder so
they get a lot of data from about the
ocean and so scientists submit their
data and all sorts of formats to this
group and then beaker demo has data
managers that go in and they clean up
the data you know they remove the
friction from their data and then they
host it and provide access for the
public and for other scientists to then
pull down that data and do analysis with
the data and be Co demo is really trying
to support reproducible research as well
oh I also want to mention that I took a
lot of these slides about Beco demo from
amber York who is one of my colleagues
at B Cody mo and she gave a great talk
at CSV conf last year and the rest of
her slides are at thes that this is a
note O link if you want to check those
out ok so I want to show you what some
of the Beco demo data looks like because
I find it it's just so messy and I find
it very interesting so for instance they
have data about coral reefs that they
receive they have data about the
salinity of the ocean water they have
data about jellyfish like they have all
sorts of interesting data and it comes
in various formats too if you can kind
of see my mouse here I'm showing you a
date range which is like all in one
column and it's not in a standard date
format so as you can see it's it's
pretty
see data and you can imagine that these
data managers have a lot of work cut out
for them so one of the big goals of our
collaboration with picot demo was to use
data package pipelines to try and help
the Beco demo data managers with this
big task of cleaning the data to try
again remove the friction from this data
process so here are some examples of
what types of things the Beco demo data
managers do to data for instance they
frequently have to add spatiotemporal
context and standard formats things like
date and time time zones latitude
longitude the depth at which the sample
was taken from the ocean and you know
often you can imagine they get data from
around the world it's in different time
zones it's in different date formats and
so they want to be able to standardize
that data so that anyone around the
world can then use it and they also have
to do things like correct quality issues
they get data that has inconsistent
formatting they have corrupt data
characters or data gaps even you know
sometimes there's wondering is that
missing value actually a missing value
or did the missing value connotes some
important information to the researcher
and then they have things like invalid
species names and also just simply typos
which I'm sure many of you are familiar
with if you've worked with data that
other people have created and so all of
this they have to reformat for
reusability
so together our team has been trying to
help them streamline this process by
working with data package pipelines and
creating a UI for the managers to use so
overall the main goal is to take this
messy data that Beco demo gets submitted
to them and then turn it into nice clean
data that they can then host for other
people to reuse and to have this entire
process be transparent and open and
reproducible so I love this slide and
this concept of like the scientists are
out you know they have a difficult job
already
working in the Arctic and then we're
also asking them well did you record the
metadata so this is where I like to
think that the frictionless data project
is April to come in and try and help
help with this great work that these
scientists are doing and make this data
really usable so how is data package
pipelines helping first of all it gives
data managers a more immersive
experience with this new improved UI and
it reduces data set processing time it
also removes the barrier programmatic
ability for the data managers and it
avoids having them have to handwrite
pipeline spec EML files or python
scripts which you know eliminates errors
and is much faster importantly you can
also add custom metadata to the pipeline
and if I think I already said this we
have some additional custom processors
that you can build into the pipeline for
instance Beco demo has several processor
steps that they do over and over again
two data files that are based on you
know ocean specific data and so they
were able to write specific processors
for their ocean data and add that to the
DPP pipelines okay I want to show you an
example of what the pipeline tool UI
looks like so you can understand it so
first of all the data manager would load
in the data and then they do different
processor steps each of these arrows is
a different processor for instance they
can round a field they can do a find and
replace they can do some computational
I'm changes to fields you do things like
convert a date or rename a field etc and
then here on the right we're showing you
an example of changing a time field and
you can see down here in the note
they've written fix in consistent time
format some didn't have seconds and you
see they add in a pattern and a replace
pattern and then the output of this
pipeline is
pipeline specky Amal file that shows the
next day - manager exactly what happened
during that pipeline run so you can see
it's enamel it's human readable we can
see oh they fixed the inconsistent time
format and why they did it and then
again this find and replace pattern that
is very repeatable and understandable so
I want to give you another example of
one type of change that happens
frequently with this data and it's
changing the date format and so here in
this first example this would be the
data that they are given and it has the
date and you know April 16th 2018 which
is how s Americans would write the date
but it's how you know no one else in the
world writes their date and it's not
standardized and so if you were
somewhere else and you're pulling down
this data it could be very difficult to
know what this date exactly meant and so
this pipeline processor took that took
that column and change the date made it
standardized so it actually ended up
with two columns the first is the ISO so
standardized date format with a time
zone and then they also kept the local
date time that made it a more standard
format and this is a pretty simple
example but it's actually really
important to be able to manipulate the
data in this way to make it more
reusable and again the output of the
data package pipeline is this change
which is documented in the pipeline spec
um will file and then you also get the
data spread out and you also get the
data package JSON file that has the
metadata included so together all of
these files are packaged and they make
this process very usable repeatable so
our main goal here was to go from this
messy data that beaker demo gets and
then run it through the pipeline and an
easy-to-use way by these data managers
and so that you output the pipeline spec
file the metadata and the data
and nice easy-to-use formats okay so
that's where we've gotten so far at this
pilot the next steps are to release the
open source community version of the
pipeline UI and so the pipeline UI isn't
quite done yet that's why it hasn't been
publicly released but they're also
released their custom processors and
they have a statistics calculator that
happens in the UI as well and then this
would allow the public to rerun
pipelines or build up upon existing
pipelines which could be really cool and
then the next step is also to integrate
good tables data validation into the
pipeline so this would allow for data
validation to occur during the pipeline
steps and to hopefully avoid things like
oh my string was turned into a date and
I just want to end by saying I can't say
enough good things about the Beco demo
group and the interesting science that
they're doing so if you're interested in
oceanography
science in any way I really encourage
you to check them out and I have listed
their website and their Twitter account
and their github where you can look at
the software that they're building ok
how am i doing on time I'm pretty good
ok I and now we're gonna get into the
stuff that I wasn't going to talk about
a lot that I just really want to leave
up here for y'all so that if you want to
play around with the frictionless data
code and tools on your own time there's
lots of links here so if you are
interested in learning more about the
frictionless data tooling I encourage
you to first start by going to our field
guide and this is a good place to start
it has tutorials and some documentation
we also have web browser tools that I
didn't talk about so in addition to
these Python libraries we have these
browser tools that anyone can use you
don't need to know any programming to
use them so for instance the data
package creator allows you to input data
from you know local or a URL and then
you can package that you can enter in
your own med
data or it will infer metadata for you
and you can download it and use it later
we also have a browser tool for good
tables and so this again will allow you
to insert data either locally or from a
URL and then validate that data either
with or without a schema and we also
have a continuous data validation form
of good tables which is integrated with
github so every time you push your new
data to github it will validate it and
here's an example of what that would
look like it will show you you know
specifically oh you had 26 errors and
these are the types of errors that you
had and this is where the error was so
you can go back and fix it all right and
with that I'm gonna end so that I have
time for questions but I want to say
thank you and also really try and push
you if you're interested to join our
community as I said we are very
community focused and so and we're all
open source so again the link to our
github repository and then the second
link is to our discuss forum where
people post you know big-picture
questions and stuff stuff that's not
only about frictionless data but stuff
about like open licensing and open data
in general and then we have a git er
chat room where you can ask technical
questions and our team will help you in
the community will also help you and
then we have some other YouTube videos
you can look at and again the field
guide and yeah I think that's it thank
you
[Applause]
in the back first yes
I'm having a hard time hearing you I
think we have a mic coming
this would help okay okay my question is
you handle a lot of data from comes from
so one source but probably many entities
are entering it when you have it there's
a lot of confusion you and you you
actually explain how and why
specifically if you have a lot of
numerical data numerical data is
associated usually with units of measure
how do you handle those do you have a
standard OID that you order two or if
not do you want to do it this is my
first question yeah
so our specifications that we have
written are very generic by design so
that people can then take them and make
them more specific so we actually have a
lot of discussion right now about this
units question because there isn't right
now the units are not built into the
specs but we've been talking about it a
lot okay what do you have okay I think
this is awesome I've been struggling
with data pipelines and I keep writing
for the last couple of months writing
code - I work in oil and gas so every
every time I go to a project every
project is completely different so one
question is what do you do when you have
to go back and correct one date one
piece of the data I think that you end
up with a CSV file but in my case see my
projects I always have to push to a
database and I find myself that I have
to correct some previous data in the
database so how do you handle those
situations I say I don't personally have
a lot of experience with that aspect but
I think typically you would rerun the
pipeline and that's why it's really
helpful to have you know everything
written down in that pipeline spec file
but yeah I think if you need to make a
change you'd probably need to rerun it
I'm just curious what kind of adoption
you've seen of this tool so far yeah so
we this projects been around for I think
10 years the frictionless data project
as a whole has been around the
specifications were released just a few
years ago and as like a v1 release and
the reproducible research specific
aspect has only been going on for a year
so with scientist we don't have as much
adoption yet because we're really trying
to build up adoption there but we have a
lot of adoption with like open
government data and spending data a lot
of budget and data I think did you have
a question first do you guys have any
plans to allow integration of something
like this into a sort of like workflow
schedule or like air flow or other sort
of larger yeah we don't have plans yet
but I would love to see something like
that happen and the reason we don't have
that specifically in our plans is
because we have such a small team and
we're really focused on working with
specific researchers to resolve their
problems so like if a researcher had
that specific use case then it would be
super cool we also have like we will
have another round of tool funds so if
you were interested and helping build
that we give out grants to build tooling
like that
um do you have any competitors are there
groups working on similar projects I
mean the the idea is it's great if the
world could all agree to use your tool
that would be phenomenal but yeah
there's probably many others projects
similar to this so in a way you have you
have like another level of meta problems
because if other people come up with
different package containers then you
still have a mess
sure have you ever seen that xkcd
cartoon that's talking about data
standards and it's like though we have
13 competing extenders and we will write
one standard to rule them all and then
it's like the next day we have 14
competing data standards so yeah this is
an issue that we've thought about a lot
and part of our specifications are meant
to be very general so that they are
maximally usable and interoperable
because you know we've really don't want
to be competing as much as we can but I
would say one of our biggest I want I
don't say competitors but another group
that we've been thinking about how we
can integrate with is schema.org and I
don't know if you've heard about Google
has a dataset search now and they use
schema.org to help like as the metadata
for that data set search so we've been
thinking about that does this tool
support versioning or anything related
to that so if one researcher wants to
update their data would that just update
the metadata piece or do you actually
need to update the whole thing could you
repeat the very beginning of your
question please does this to support
versioning on the data set yes it does
support versioning
yeah
so for the scientific community its
usual to not just like adopt some kind
of specification but most like built an
organic way of organizing data and since
the data can be really complex like
genetic or reimaged data it is usually
comes from the community per se to build
these kind of specifications so I guess
not more in the technical aspect but
more in the organizational aspects how
is the the foundation targets to
encompass this kind of organization
these kind of specifications like the
the brain injury data specification yeah
that's a great question and it's
something that we're still working on
and it's part of just like as building
up our network and talking to people
that are you know like using the bid
specification and trying to learn more
about their needs and then trying to
figure out how we can work together to
answer those needs so yeah I don't have
a specific answer yet because we're
still working on it that's really I
think I have a quick question on
something or for now we can just we had
a fourth through your github account
yeah no you can pip install everything
yeah any questions thank you
you